[Música]
los líderes europeos se dan cita en
bruselas para una cumbre de cuatro días
sobre temas que pasan por la crisis en
belarús las tensiones de turquía chipre
y grecia por los recursos energéticos en
el mediterráneo entretanto la comisión
europea emprendió acciones legales
contra reino unido por la ley de mercado
interno que violaría los acuerdos de
precios
en el día nacional de china hay una
nueva jornada de protestas en convocó la
oposición prodemocrática pide la
liberación de presos políticos ya fueron
arrestadas al menos 60 personas por las
movilizaciones consideradas ilegales
y argentina enfrenta un pico de crisis
en la pandemia según datos oficiales el
primer semestre del año 40 9% de la
población está en situación de pobreza
un informe denuncia que la falta de
ingresos afecta casi hasta la mitad de
la población
comienza la mañana y también las
noticias de france 24 mi nombre es
ángela gómez buenos dias iniciamos el
informativo en europa los líderes de la
unión europea se reúnen en una cumbre de
cuatro días para tratar de avanzar en
varios temas que han quedado estancados
y que sobrepasan sus fronteras dado que
en el bloque las decisiones se toman por
unanimidad varios asuntos clave se han
visto bloqueados la influencia del
bloque está en juego dependiendo de las
decisiones que tome
la atención en el mediterráneo oriental
es uno de los principales temas que los
líderes europeos tienen que tratar
turquía ha enviado barcos de perforación
en aguas disputadas que grecia y chipre
dicen que les pertenecen la unión
europea se ha visto dividida entre un
enfoque de confrontación defendido por
parís y atenas incluyendo sanciones
contra los funcionarios turcos y
llamadas al diálogo impulsadas por
alemania en un intento de forzar a
bruselas a enfrentarse a turquía chipre
ha bloqueada otra crisis
belarús la unión europea condenando la
forma en que las autoridades manejaron
el voto presidencial negándose a
reconocer la reelección de alexander
lukachenko y criticando la represión de
las protestas pero chipre ha bloqueado
los esfuerzos para imponer sanciones
mostrando una vez más lo fácil que puede
ser el bloqueo de la unión europea
los líderes europeos se reúnen mientras
un violento conflicto regional entre
armenia y azerbayán se recrudece en la
región de nagorno karabaj como muchas
potencias mundiales el bloque ha pedido
un alto el fuego y diálogo turquía se ha
puesto del lado de azerbaiyán y aumenta
el riesgo de que el conflicto se
intensifique la unión europea hasta
ahora no ha encontrado un enfoque unido
para detener a ankara en cuanto a la
crisis de kobe la unión europea tiene
que avanzar en su fondo de estímulo de
750 mil millones de euros los líderes
del bloque siguen divididos sobre las
posibles condiciones necesarias para
acceder a los fondos y sobre si hay que
actualizar el acuerdo ahora que la
pandemia está en aumento en varios de
los estados miembros
entre tanto la comisión europea anunció
el inicio de acciones legales contra el
reino unido por la ley de mercado
interno que según bruselas cambian los
términos del break city en cuanto a la
frontera irlandesa la presidenta de la
comisión curso el a vanderlei en explicó
la decisión tras la la pcia estrella la
fecha límite se cumplía ayer las
cláusulas problemáticas no han sido
removidas
así que esta mañana la comisión ha
decidido enviar una carta de aviso
formal al gobierno de río ha unido este
es el primer paso en un procedimiento de
infracción
esta carta invita al gobierno británico
a enviar sus observaciones en el próximo
mes
exacto además la comisión continuará
trabajando hacia una implementación
total y a tiempo del acuerdo de salida
defendemos nuestro compromiso stand by
our home beat más íbamos al reino unido
con nuestra corresponsal a marcela
gutiérrez buen día para ustedes marcela
y quiero comenzar preguntándole por las
reacciones de los británicos después de
este anuncio de la comisión europea la
acción legal ya se veía venir
así es el gobierno británico ha sido
contundente en su negación de retirar
esta controvertida ley del mercado
interno que es lo que ha provocado este
inicio que podría iniciar una larga
disputa legal y esto porque los europeos
consideran que gran bretaña estaría
violando el acuerdo del break si este
acuerdo que fue firmado el año pasado
entre el reino unido y la unión europea
sin embargo hoy un portavoz del gobierno
británico aseguró que van a responder a
la unión europea en su debido curso
tienen un mes para hacerlo y también el
gobierno del político conservador boris
johnson ha dicho una y otra vez que esta
ley del mercado interno es para
salvaguardar el mercado del reino unido-
sobre todo en lo que respecta a irlanda
del norte e irlanda para evitar una
frontera dura en esta región y sobre
todo para proteger el acuerdo de viernes
santo que puso fin
a varios años de conflictos en irlanda
del norte así que estamos esperando más
reacciones del gobierno británico sobre
lo que dijo hoy la unión europea
bueno marcela y le cambió de tema porque
hoy en el reino unido también es noticia
el último día de audiencia contra el
fundador de wikileaks julian assange que
podría ser extraditado a eeuu que se
espera como conclusión de la jornada
ya estamos al final de esta audiencia
que ha durado un poco más de tres
semanas todavía hay algunas semanas más
para que la defensa de julian assange
presente su argumento final no se tomará
la decisión sobre su extradición ni el
día de hoy ni el día de mañana sino que
podrían pasar algunos meses antes del
veredicto final y hay
una reunión aquí desde temprana hora se
han dado cita a manifestantes
simpatizantes a la causa de assange que
están pidiendo su liberación inmediata y
sobre todo que no sea extraditado a los
estados unidos ha sido un gran drama
durante estas tres semanas adentro de la
fuente donde muchos de los periodistas
han podido entrar y los testimonios de
la defensa a superación de testimonios
ayuda lanzas y evitar esta extradición a
la estabilidad
gracias a ustedes marcela y vamos a hong
kong miles de policías y fuerzas de
seguridad se apostaron en las calles
para el día nacional de china oficiales
informaron que ya fueron detenidas al
menos 60 personas el año pasado se
produjeron violentos enfrentamientos en
la fiesta del país asiático y beijing
que quiere evitar nuevos choques y que
el movimiento prodemocracia en hong kong
recobre impulso
cortando de raíz cualquier signo de
disidencia a los pocos momentos de
levantar sus pancartas estos
manifestantes prodemocracia fueron
acosados por la policía en el día
nacional de china un día festivo que
para estos hongkoneses no es de
celebración sino de luto por las
libertades perdidas exigimos al gobierno
comunista chino que acabe con su
dictadura unipartidista
que devuelva el poder al pueblo chino
exigimos que derogue la ley de seguridad
y que se libere a todos los prisioneros
políticos demandas que fueron
respaldadas por el prominente activista
yo soy walk durante el período de
vacaciones chinas las fuerzas de
seguridad se han desplegado en masa en
hong kong se cree que unos seis mil
oficiales están en las calles para
anular cualquier manifestación las
reuniones de cuatro personas están
prohibidas oficialmente por el riesgo
del coronavirus pero también para evitar
que se repitan los hechos de 2019 el año
pasado en el 70 aniversario del día
nacional de china cientos de miles de
residentes de hong kong salir
las calles se produjeron violentos
enfrentamientos en toda la ciudad pero
desde entonces ha habido represión el 30
de junio entró en vigor la ley de
seguridad impuesta por el gobierno chino
para la líder de hong kong apoyada por
beijing ha sido un éxito
en los últimos meses es un hecho
indiscutible que nuestra sociedad ha
vuelto a la paz la ley de seguridad
nacional ha protegido a hong kong y
nuestros ciudadanos pueden volver a
ejercer sus derechos de acuerdo con la
ley
sin embargo los manifestantes
prodemocracia dicen que están siendo
perseguidos y que ya no pueden expresar
su disentimiento sin ser encarcelados en
los últimos 16 meses unos 10.000
hongkoneses han sido detenidos en las
protestas hay manifestaciones en irak
frente al ministerio de educación
superior y aquí se reunieron cientos de
jóvenes para luego dirigirse hacia la
plaza tahrir de bagdad para conmemorar
el primer aniversario de las protestas
masivas el sindicato de estudiantes
demanda la lucha contra la corrupción y
el cambio político además pide cuentas
por el asesinato de manifestantes
durante las movilizaciones de los
últimos años y por recientes ataques
contra activistas en todo el país
el primer ministro mustafa al kadima y
el presidente iraquí barajan sal y se
comprometieron a cumplir con las
demandas vamos al análisis nos acompaña
vía skype desde buenos aires argentina
ezequiel coppel experto en medio oriente
ezequiel buen día gracias por estar con
nosotros y un año después de las
protestas que llevaron a la renuncia del
primer ministro adel abdul mahdi como es
el panorama en irak
hablar ir a que se encuentra en nueva
disyuntiva tanto política como de
seguridad hay un problema de referente
vida política en cuanto a que los
manifestantes o activistas dicen que el
sistema electoral impuesto por el estado
de la ocupación de irak en 2005 no
garantiza que candidatos independientes
pueden imponerse en el parlamento
entonces lo que se pide es una reforma
política a pesar de la hecha diciembre
del 2019 que alcance que sea de alguna
manera más que en que se pueda extender
un poco más sin que alcance a cualquier
candidato independiente pueda
presentarse después también hay un
problema de control del estado
hay un montón de milicias que también
han penetrado el estado está en el
parlamento que han crecido en una
especie de vacío de poder incluso de
seguridad cuando y si se avanza en irak
que han ocupado ciertos roles del estado
entonces lo que estamos viendo es casi
una disyuntiva en quien va contra el
estado inicial que responden a veces a
intereses extranjeros que puede ser irán
o el propio ejército
e iraquí y su policía y por último
tenemos un problema de seguridad que es
un posible avance y crecimiento del
estado islámico y este último punto y
así es que había nombrado antes era del
control del estado digamos que se agrava
cuando y se va creciendo la amenaza de
si va creciendo y las milicias chiítas
son upa en el lugar que el ejército y
aquí no puede no puede no puede ocupar
bueno y en las protestas del año pasado
se registraron las muertes de cientos de
estudiantes cuál es la posición del
gobierno
con esta pelota para adelante los
manifestantes es que va adelantar las
elecciones la situación es la fecha para
adelantar la serie a mitad del año que
viene no mentira te dicen que esto no es
lo que están buscando muchos dicen
también principalmente más que alentar
elecciones que hace una reforma del
espectador donde cualquier cantidad
indecente puede imponer si puede
imponerse un aparato que de alguna
manera replicar cierto sistema sectario
que ya conocemos en el líbano y como
vimos también representa el líbano tanto
con irak con todos estas esta
magnificación es lo que están diciendo
que es más obsoleto que no garantiza la
democracia y que cambiar el ministro no
es la solución al problema de que cambie
el sistema político de cuajo gracias a
ustedes se ve por su análisis y
finalizamos en américa latina porque
argentina registra uno de los peores
indicadores de pobreza de su historia
según cifras de la oficina estatal de
estadística en el primer semestre del
año había un 40,9 por ciento de personas
viviendo bajo este flagelo nos lo cuenta
juan pupiales
con una economía en recesión desde hace
dos años la pandemia llegó a argentina
como otro golpe más con una cuarentena
que se decretó en marzo y ha empezado a
flexibilizarse desde mayo la pobreza se
muestra como un indicador al alza en
medio de este panorama según el
instituto nacional de estadística de
pobreza alcanzó en el primer semestre
del año el 49 por ciento de la población
un repunte de más de 5 puntos sobre el
final de año pero según unas
estimaciones anticipadas de la
universidad católica de argentina hasta
junio la pobreza era de entre el 46% y
el 47% shock han sido en la estructura
productiva la declinación de cuenta
propia incluso informal bueno entonces
mayor pobreza general todos somos un
poco más pobre ya lo hubiéramos afín y
el año pasado
ahora más
compasión es igualdad durante la
cuarentena en argentina se han destruido
tres millones y medio de puestos de
trabajo la mayoría informales como el de
guillermo 15 gana la vida como vendedor
ambulante en eventos deportivos
sobreviví por la familia que me apoyaba
pero era apoyaba también económicamente
porque no tenía ninguna posibilidad de
hacer nada no hay no habían en ningún
evento como pasaría a vender mi trabajo
como para hacer el gobierno ha dado
subsidios de unos 125 dólares mensuales
a 9 millones de personas y también
promueve los comedores populares de
acuerdo con las cifras oficiales más de
la mitad de los niños son pobres y en el
segundo trimestre del año la caída del
producto interior bruto fue de un 19,1
por ciento es el peor dato de este tipo
desde que se realiza el registro incluso
superando el del primer trimestre del
2002 que fue el 16 3% en medio de la
crisis del corralito
llegamos al final del informativo pero
usted continúe con nosotros y recuerde
también seguirnos en france24 punto com
buenos días
[Música]